>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SLAMMING LONG-TIME HILLARY
CLINTON AID HUMA ABEDIN
OF WORK-RELATED EMAILS FROM
ABEDIN'S ACCOUNT.
THEY WERE FOUND ON HER
ESTRANGED HUSBAND ANTHONY
WEINER HE IS THE GUY IN JAIL
LAB TOP.
JUDICIAL WATCH SUED THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TO GET
THESE EMAILS REPORTING THAT
FIVE OF THE DOCUMENTS
OH, I THOUGHT THEY WERE
ABOUT YOGA AND A WEDDING AND
PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL WATCH
WHY DID IT TAKE SO LONG TO
GET THESE?
YOU FILED FOR THESE IN,
WHAT, 2015?
>> YEAH.
WELL, IT'S THE DEEP STATE.
THE FBI FOUND THESE RECORDS
BACK IN OCTOBER OF LAST
YEAR.
AND IT'S 14 MONTHS LATER.
AND THEY FINALLY TURNED THEM
OVER TO US.
A LITTLE UNDER 700 OR 800
EMAILS U AND THEY SHOW THE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION,
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WAS
ON THE LAPTOP OF ANTHONY
WEINER.
TO SAY THAT, I THINK, IS
GOING TO REALLY INFURIATE A
LOT OF THE AMERICANS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE
SECURITY CLEARANCES AND THEY
ARE ASKING WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS ASKING, WHY
WASN'T THERE A SERIOUS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION OR
THERE BUT FOR HILLARY
CLINTON'S DECISION TO SET UP
THIS SECRET EMAIL SERVER.
HUMA ABEDIN TESTIFIED LAST
YEAR, SEAN, THAT IT WAS
HILLARY CLINTON'S IDEA TO
GET THE SYSTEM UP AND
RUNNING.
THIS IS THE RESULT, THIS
VIOLATION OF LAW AND THIS
RISK TO NATIONAL SECURITY IS
ANTHONY WEINER'S COMPUTER
SYSTEM.
>> Sean: PAM, THEY KNEW LAWS
WERE BROKEN.
NOW WE HAVE THE EMAILS.
WE HAVE JOHN SOLOMON'S
REPORT.
THEY WERE SHOCKED AT THE
AMOUNT OF CLASSIFIED
KNOW THE FIX WAS IN.
IT WAS RIGGED TO QUOTE
CONGRESSMAN MATT KING.
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS.
THIS HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH THE SECURITY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE TOP SECRET
SECURITY CLEARANCE THAT HUMA
ABEDIN HAD, YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU SEND THOSE EMAILS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT WOULD NOT
CHARGE HER BASED ON THAT.
NOW -- DON'T WE HAVE A CASE
OF OBSTRUCTION, PAM, FOR HIM
>> AND THAT'S WHY CONGRESS
IS CALLING THEM IN.
I THINK STRZOK IS IN
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TROUBLE.
I THINK COMEY IS GOING TO BE
IN TROUBLE.
I THINK IN HIS MIND THE BEST
DEFENSE IS A GOOD OFFENSE
AND THAT'S WHAT HE IS TRYING
PROBLEMS AS WELL AS SHE
SHOULD.
>> Sean: YOUR REACTION, TOM
INVESTIGATION WAS
COMPROMISED AND NEEDS TO BE
REDONE.
YOU HAVE THE CLINTON-LORETTA
LYNCH CAR PACK MEETING.
CLINTON MACHINATIONS.
PRO-HILLARY AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
HAD YOU ANDREW MCCABE WHOSE
WIFE HAD JUST GOTTEN A TOP
OF MONEY FROM HILLARY
CLINTON'S KROHNY.
WHAT EVIDENCE DO YOU NEED?
EVEN PROSECUTED AT THE END.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU NOT GET
INDICTED THESE ARE FELONIES.
>> WE NEED AN HONEST
INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT YET.
JEFF SESSION OR WHOEVER IS
INVOLVED IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO STEP IN.
>> Sean: DO YOUR JOB.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD ORDER
THEM TO DO AN HONEST